if they were like fire alarm starts
going off and you're like what you'd be
like Oh today I'm gonna be trying a
portable steam sauna don't know exactly
what that means but I know I'm probably
gonna get really sweaty I feel like you
guys are gonna put me in a makeshift spa
castle kind of little like Amazon Prime
I like saunas I like anything hot hot
tubs saunas I love them all I love
saunas I love like sweating with a bunch
of half-naked dudes it's America's
greatest pastime whoa it looks like a
robot costume if there are too many
steps then it's it's gonna be bad for me
okay so first bring out bottom two this
feels like I'm building my kids crib so
next we need these directions are not
easy to understand this looks promising
cuz they're calling these like side
tubes and back tubes but like why don't
they call it like curves tube with no
connectors on the end do you break this
down every and build it up every time
you want to use it because like maybe
just get in the car and drive to a sauna
all right sometimes you just got to give
a little puppet for us you know then it
works right look at that come on baby
come on baby and I'm already so sweaty
ma'am turning it on I want to relax this
dress
I'm in I'm in I think the pill box is
something you want to avoid I want to go
in and take off my pants though because
I don't want to get my pants off so so
I'm going into my shell I feel like
these are my hands these are somebody
else's hands and they're like feeding me
food don't tell my girlfriend I got
naked at work all right
damn it gets hot it does really get hot
in here feel like I just got transported
to the beach see all that sweat look at
it it's working see that I'm listening
I'm here guys I survived it was
wonderful was beautiful my body
temperature is cooled down my legs
aren't as glisteny and my sweat smells
very good if I was going to like a
bachelorette party I would definitely
consider bringing it
you know it just it just seems like
bachelorette party is doing relaxation
pedis and stuff and then it's like oh
you guys are doing Petty's what about a
sauna and all the girls would be like
yeah if I had a change of clothes I
definitely would have stayed in there
forever
hands down it was it was it was good
spot cast on your living room guys I
don't know maybe I could do some drugs
and go on a spirit journey in here I
don't really know
[Music]